hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to tears of blood now if
there ever was a horror game with a more
horror game name than tears of blood I
would like to be told what that is a
five-night at prom boys oh okay alright
hello
why are you thrusting your hands through
that lady that sounds out of context
very bad but in context it's why me it's
not good but I'm just gonna meander over
this way excuse me oh all the younglings
learning always good to see also why is
everything so slightly creepy and why am
I here and why are there are showers and
what did you what are you talking about
YouTube what you're talking about the
YouTube in hood why do my body keep
thrusting itself towards the camera
again doesn't sound good in context but
the car I can't go there
doodly-doo I'm not askin doodly-doo my
way over here to the cafeteria I suppose
if there's something here that I'm
supposed to get is there something air
that I'm supposed to do
Oh locked great do I need to find a key
for that you need to find my way into
the classroom with all the kids nope oh
yes there we go hello oh good we're on
dune I thought we were on earth for a
second
I like the giant boob hill over there
that's awfully nice oh where are we
going to hell I hope it's all God
hi hello what are you crying what's
going on alright even I'm gonna be ander
over this way not gonna bother you
Lockette uh good dude great oh I don't
like the old-timey music going on over
there and something's wrong with this
pool I'm gonna dive in and check oh
locked I need to find a key I think I'm
not a hundred percent sure about that
one but maybe who's been bashed down I
wonder if there's anything fun happening
over here Hilaire Oh okey goody okay
well I got a key
I don't know what that means phenomenom
sprint as fast as I can over here
through the school that I thought I knew
oh good can we loop one more on the
planet of doon in boob Hill
oh it's mount boob I'm sorry I
pronounced that run hi okay Oh
alrighty then
[Laughter]
[Music]
call me off-guard
hey you're taller than and beat about oh
oh I don't know what's that oh you're
dead apparently oh no and now it's gonna
kill me oh my god oh well alright I
guess I'm gonna go here then is it
coming after me I can't even tell good
thing I'm so good at moonwalking I can
moonwalk away from that oh hi hello-o
police officers I thought you were just
creepy people standing in the middle of
the hallway oh yeah I don't know how to
explain this one she got drunk kicked
huh her skulls caved in from a sweet
drop kick to the face skedaddle over
this my [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't do that
I'm not prepared can I go in the showers
and oh no I what are you doing over
there
why are you staring at that blood do you
really need to be on your hands and
knees looking that closely at that blood
so why was there blood over
I don't remember Luke ooh I can't see in
here well I'm not assumed that I don't
need to go into the black void of the
pool so I'm gonna continue on the way I
know I should go this way
mr. director why won't you open your
door well so why am i hearing this
police here
what am I just a meandering observer in
this universe of death oh I need to find
a key do I do I really I bet it's back
in the pool the black oblivion that I
didn't want to go and do but that's the
one wasn't in here somewhere
great this is my flashlight on ok so
there's got to be some over here
definitely not in there
what's this nope that's a big old
negative on that one all right
have you seen a key now you keep looking
in that pool of blood I'll eventually
get back to it key nobody got a key oh I
found a key hey everybody I found a key
it's probably vital to the investigation
that you're pulling all right sure ok
I'm gonna go over here to wherever the
back of the kitchen leads cuz I'm sure
that's gonna help me escape this
hellhole sure do love being trapped in
hell holes hello who's back here yes is
it Oh an elevator
Oh to turn up to turn on the elevator
that's not it that is not an elevator
that's a hole in the ground you wouldn't
know the difference between an elevator
and your ass and a hole in the ground
you son of a [ __ ] but I'm gonna go jump
in that hole and see where it leads me
cops don't worry about me I'm about to
go jump down a hole okay we love you
Thanks what friendly police officers
okay Oh
where am i where am i oh I saw a burning
cross okay ah good the land of thorns
and inverted shadows oh good alrighty
then why am I here why am I here why am
I here what have you got in store for me
I'm not sure if it's creepy or cool but
kind of cool kind of will be doubled up
we're gonna call it oh there's that
burning cross that I saw so much Oh
someone's on it
ah let that dropkick lady Oh sheep it's
rough time in this neighborhood Oh am I
going to jump why am I going to do all I
have to jump now
oh no don't slap me not a sweet dropkick
huh okay alright then that seems like
thorns oh hey hey hey hey no none of
that none of that none of that hey what
do you think you're doing huh you doing
the dance I don't want to handy boy that
you say over me
gross cooties no don't cut off my escape
route right well it's locked I got to
find a kid I got to find one of those
sweet kids before he gets me open battle
all I gots to open that up now don't
stick me pee
why why did you put me what did you
blood those cops how could you be
blotting so much around here
ah and your dropkick has a lot more
range than I suspected all right yeah
yeah that's right go in the pool but so
the fast whoa a those are fast they
don't do none of that none of that is no
good all of that is known as a [ __ ]
[ __ ] why why now why now Sid you
suddenly get jump scary I got a key I
found three keys iiiiii I got your yard
locked Oh
Luke I don't know where to go for this
hi excuse you all
that's alrighty then I'm why is that one
okay well this is open but now it's
closed
is it open or closed I don't know you're
hot then you're cold you're yes then
you're no you're opening your clothes
there's no elevator it is not an
elevator that is the opposite of an
elevator oh boy oh boy elbowing go bonk
OH
Oh bingo bonk oh okay don't block me I
don't want to be blooded you can barely
see through all the flickering oh I'm
safe and sound no no no non-event no
dropkicks in here oh yeah you me and
roll slowly don't worry get rekt it Oh
check the feelings the monsters or drop
goddamnit you can't drop me oh well just
saw one of the law honey isn't it that
wasn't intended for those delirious high
it was this guy's first game or girls do
this person's first game that was
actually not that bad actually that was
not that bad it was uh it was pretty
good it had a lot of flaws a lot of
things that I laughed
honestly no there's some potential here
it was just a little bit crude but I can
see how you executed a few concepts here
it wasn't it wasn't too bad so I liked
it so thank you for making it everybody
watched it let me know what you thought
if it down becomes glow and thanks for
watching if you want to play for
yourself check out the look at the
difference so thanks again and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]